when we didn't have bookers i sat my
guys and i said guys why do you think
it's tough to interview a mark cuban i
said i'm going to be the booker and i'm
going to show you we're going to
interview mark cuban so i reached out to
mark cuban and we got an interview with
mark cuban six months later and it was
an exchange what are you looking for i
said hey do you want to i can sell you
10 000 copies of your book he says you
think i need 10 000 copies at 65
no he says but what i do have is an app
i wouldn't mind driving
when we were small
you do everything
you're like you're you're recruiting
you're promoting you're selling you're
driving you're doing this you have to
wear so many hats when you're small
building your business up that you can't
be saying like kind of yesterday we had
a couple people that were consulting
that they came up here two partners
they're about to finish the business
together the business doing five six
million dollars a year they're like
we're done okay and it's an ugly meeting
okay
and it's a uh it's a software business
that they have their best friends so
they decide to go into business together
and i said okay do you want to be in
business with him i don't know do you
want to be in business with him i don't
know what do you like about your partner
tell me what you like about your partner
give me three things what do you not
like about your part and give three
things what do you not like about it
give me that what do you like about this
party give three things okay so here's
what's gonna happen
if you don't change this he's gonna
leave if you keep going like that you're
not going to get the best out of them so
what do you guys want to do what is a
vision so finally we wrote down
that a company that sold 420 million
dollars for them i said is this a nice
exit for you because the other guy runs
eight businesses i'd love to do that do
you believe you guys can do this yes how
long do you think it'll take to get to
this place five years what if it gets to
half the price 60 million you guys so
you get 30 million you get 30 million oh
you're very happy with that so why don't
we solve for this so what should we do i
said here's what you should be doing i
give this advice to another guy
yesterday in real estate i was
consulting this is what i said i would
do
i said number one
who are the killers of your industry 20
years ago who are no longer competing
because whoever you talk to that's
competing they're not going to give you
a hundred percent of the best advice but
if you talk to people who were in your
industry 20 years ago i want you to make
a list of anybody who exited did very
well for themselves find them guess what
they do they make a list they found the
guy that exited for 45 million dollars i
said i guarantee you if you call him
he's in his 70s all he wants to do at
that point of his life is to make sure
his time was worth
living and he wants to give value back
to the next generation that's his legacy
him helping you is a big deal to him he
says pat we called the founder of this
company that sold this company 12 years
ago he was on the phone with us for an
hour he wants to have dinner with me my
wife and him and his wife to tell us
everything we ought to do to take the
company to the next one the guy wants
nothing from us right
this these are the things that you gotta
do behind closed doors nobody knows how
business works when you first do youtube
you don't come with a background of
youtube and when you first do real
estate you don't come with a background
of real estate when you first do
insurance you don't come with a
background of insurance but the hustle
of you being able to figure it out on
how to pull it off and learn and get
better that's who ends up winning by the
way in every single industry across the
board so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]